au cours de l'occupation russe la ville
d'hier pin a été particulièrement
touchés ici il n'ya pas un immeuble qui
était été épargnés soit par l'artillerie
soit par l'aviation le récit des
habitants est effroyable il nous parle
de viols des exécutions sommaires ou de
tortures
je les ai souvent dû abattre des gens
simplement parce qu'il marchait dans la
rue
j'ai vu des femmes qui avait été violé
l'une d'entre elles et c'est une
histoire terrible que n'oublierai jamais
avec à peine 15 ans elle était retenue
dans un sous-sol
tchétchène aucun autre groupe ethnique
et bien par des soldats russes d'environ
20 ans
j'ai enterré mon mari le 20 mars
maintenant mes enfants me soutiennent
ils me disent que je dois tourner la
page et ne jamais me retourne et
maman on m'a appelé elle était effrayée
elle avait entendu la frappe tout
tremblait sous ses pieds l'immeuble
bouger
et environ deux semaines après le départ
des troupes russes du nord de l'ukraine
les policiers sont déjà à pied d'oeuvre
il essaye de récupérer un maximum de
preuves des crimes des soldats russes
pour les transmettre ensuite aux
autorités compétentes comme la cour
pénale internationale
une femme nous a téléphoné elle était
sans nouvelles de son oncle en arrivant
ici on n'a vu qu'une roquette avait
frappé son balcon là on voit comment la
roquette a détruit sur l'appartement
l'homme était sur son balcon en train de
fumer une cigarette et d'ousmane moumen
portail nombre de ses ouvriers
le rôle de la police tire pin et
d'arrêter les pilleurs qui vole les
maisons
trouver les collaborateurs qui ont aidé
les militaires russes
déminer et désamorcer les abus non
explosées
les autorités ukrainiennes affirme avoir
découvert 900 cadavres dans la région de
kiev 900 civils dont 150 uniquement airs
pin elle affirme également avoir
identifié 200 soldats russes qui étaient
en poste dans cette zone pendant
l'occupation deux cents soldats russes
que les ukrainiens espère désormais
traduire en justice
ces nouveaux affrontements à jérusalem
en plein rama